[Music]
and I'm innocent news
I'm a nonsense the earth goodbye gesture
the JK oh thank you amen bronze
conversation from the state after being
wrongly imprisoned at age thirty what
they do get competition right like we're
taking some how did he go to jail for
like not even his fall he falsely
confessed he Brendan Dassey and pretty
much he does that do the how to make a
murder this is it how to make a murder
is that the miss yeah yeah he's a guy
that was like he's like a kid and
because he's kind of like on a little
bit slow and he was able to get
pressured and kind of coaxed into answer
in a certain way and then when
everything gets revealed he's like wait
did I just say all those things so this
guy his name is Tyler
he's now 27 years old [ __ ] you know he
spent four years in prison street cred
he got a life sentence when he was
sentenced but he spent four years yes Oh
before I got my return he was a high
school in jail he got convicted when he
was 15 so then yeah I'm gonna show you
guys a clip and he's gonna tell you guys
his experience and that means he went to
winter formal with all of his jail
buddies new kid I wonder what a jail
prom is like yeah I mean I don't know if
they had like grad night inside the
juvie hall and then they had like the
program orange toffee-nosed yeah
Dumb and Dumber didn't hang out with the
lady jail I got coolers and then they
have like a date and then they do like
jail prom was too clearly known all over
this that time in prison took so many
experiences away from me I bet didn't
get to go to prom
Oh Chrissie convinced me to confess at
her mother's house that's when she told
me that she was the one who killed Joey
she started telling me things like I
need you to take the blame for it I need
you to do this you're 13 doesn't it
happened to you they don't punish
children nothing's going to happen to
you me never has much been sent to the
principal's office before believe der
your name television age 13 the cops of
initially called my mom and said hey we
need to talk to Tyler they asked my
mother to step out of the room and then
another investigator slides in the room
when they've got her occupied and he's
holding up papers in his hand flashing
in my face then we already know that you
did this Christian told us all about it
after I said I don't believe you I don't
believe you they go and get Chrissy and
bring Christian who's in an orange
jumpsuit and handcuffs those pressures
combined just burped me and that's when
I said okay I'll tell you well I'm gonna
keep you talking with my team do you
know what you tell me your child in the
chart of bride
oh look at money thank you for real
doing on target you just tell them by it
there are so many facets I guess of
prison life that you can't really
understand unless you've lived it there
are things that I saw and experience
that I don't think any child should ever
have to experience my mother that is one
of the toughest women that I know I know
that she would never give up
Tyler's defense was was pretty expensive
but I had retired from my job and I had
a 401k
I had liquidated everything I had and
I'll be in debt for the rest of my life
we're gonna hear the voice of the court
clerk we the jury find the defendant and
there was a dramatic pause not guilty
and I just fell apart I mean it was like
having a parked car on top of you and it
just
and someone breathed life back into you
[Music]
considering that my mom literally gave
up everything that she had you know her
life in her house her husband her
financial security
getting the compensation from the state
means everything to me in the sense that
is my opportunity to say let me help you
in a way that I probably won't ever have
the opportunity to do otherwise for
people who say or believe that the state
didn't do anything wrong the
investigators and the District Attorney
took advantage of my age and my naivety
and use that to benefit themselves in
the form of maybe being able to say that
they solve the case you don't take
advantage of children I don't care what
your reasons are you don't do that to a
child
yes damn [ __ ] crazy man if that was
me and then they I found out I was going
to jail I would have made a scene like
hey Christy I thought you told me I'm
not gonna go to jail I said this [ __ ]
yeah she didn't say nothing no open I
would have been in court like excuse me
times out times out judge
Christy told me that if I lied then I
don't have to go to jail so I was trying
to save her but now I'm finding out I'm
going to jail so does that mean that we
could do a do-over rematch Lehman was
the reason why he didn't out and sister
immediately well yeah could be no right
he said that he likes saw her as like
you know like she could do no wrong if
she loved her like whoa [ __ ] he did not
think at all that she would be lying to
him so yeah like after he spent a couple
of nights in jail and then she kept
trying to talk to his lawyer but for
some reason a lawyer wouldn't show up
and that's why I took days but so he
says I candid up sending like notes to
the people in prison I like you know I'm
innocent Lee can I talk to someone
finally that's when he recanted his
confession saying like you know no it
was me was actually [ __ ] to me or what
I've been denied by good I don't know a
lot about the sister but I do know that
she is
serving a life sentence including said
it was but she had both of them did it
[ __ ]
I forgot this beautiful got murdered her
boyfriend half-sister from his dad side
so her husband they she shot him in his
sleep and so she was trying to pin it on
Tyler that's a [ __ ] but he's a little
kid little [ __ ] thirteen-year-old kids
that's pressure to that [ __ ] man
that's that I don't think she should die
I think she should lose her feet and
hands I'll be tight I wonder how people
get there you know to me like you have
to be in a very specific my state to
want to kill somebody back close to you
you know it's almost like like you feel
like you the out-of-body experiences you
just you're just like in a trance and
you just all emotion no and they're
right when you do it it goes away then
what the [ __ ] did I just do because I
I'm not like trying to say are you like
and I always say like [ __ ] those people
but a part of me wants to like
understand what's going on in their head
because clearly there's has to be some
type of remorse about your whole life
taken away there are other people who do
that and they feel like they don't have
any emotion to it like robots
yeah right but there's people who do it
and they're like what the [ __ ] did I
just do it's not like when you get into
a fight as a kid to you know like you
get so enraged being the share somebody
and next thing you know you know you're
what the [ __ ] you know I was apologized
on my next day at school elementary
school your apologize like a we cool
even high schoolers that already doing
high school I glad I could do it this is
so crazy man so he lost four years of
his life and then somehow he was able to
like be set free not somehow his mom I
mean but like somehow her he had he was
able to prove that he was innocent
yeah this is a lot of hard work yeah
that's awesome one of the mom ever gave
up on him I never and then so that video
is a lot longer so I was trimmed down to
show you guys but in that video she's
also saying like you know when someone
asks me like what is your child's life
worth like what is your child's life or
you know like she gave up everything in
her life for her son yeah I'm wondering
what happened specifically in the court
what he said to prove his innocence
I'm wondering maybe there was um because
it was like a recording of the
interrogation and they probably did
something like not people like a Brendan
Dassey news yeah you did do this yeah
that's [ __ ] up that they came in with
respective papers like that type of
pressure I don't think he put that on a
kid
yeah and they like removed his mom be
distracted that's probably one of the
biggest things that they [ __ ] up on I
mean it's also hard looking at the cops
I they're trying to get to the truth but
any other using these aggressive tactics
but I can see why they would want to
separate it because what if the moms
like not you you know I mean like yeah I
don't know who to trust
it's really hard like I get you know I'm
definitely on your guys's by when it's
like damn I could for thirteen year old
or whatever you know like you said she's
still naive and so easily influenced but
you know they're just trying to get to
the bottom of the truth you know I don't
know if I could even blame the cops all
I'm saying is [ __ ] Christie yeah yeah
she's a [ __ ] [ __ ] ass [ __ ] is she
trying to swim no 13 year old kid no man
they need a soul her lips together and
she can only eat through her nostrils
I like that all the food you know when
you get rice stuck in between your nose
and your mouth that's how that she could
only eat [ __ ] right through her nose
that's happened here often
mmhmm yeah yeah never had that
especially when you guys haven't ate
enough rice yeah they should sentence
Christy to work for his mom for the rest
of the mom's life I like that to make
that money back because this whole
fiasco was caused by her yep how much
money is he asking for he's asking for
one hundred and fifty thousand dollars
although it's not even that much from
where they're at it could be a lot
though think government still I mean
that's not much at all no matter where
you're at 150 thousand dollars for a
government institution still nothing
yeah we were not Marcia Thomas mr.
history is asking for that much from the
state lawyer he's an American do that
she's gonna be paying for that for the
rest of her life like she said yeah
obviously she doesn't make a lot of
money you know yeah oh yeah she's
retired yeah yeah that's insane man [ __ ]
man it reminds me of the Slender Man
thing remember those girls yeah at a
murder Beck and honey didn't they did
murder her right
no no she survived she escaped the
forest
yeah they stabbed her and then she
escaped that she survived oh yeah yeah
yeah she survived and the reason why
they did is because they're trying to
see if they can discover Slenderman or
something no that's not even how the
game works yeah weird [ __ ] though the
Bratz [ __ ]
well I'm just glad like they were able
to prove innocence and he has you know
his life now but he didn't get to go to
Winter Formal you should start making
rap albums because he has a street cred
now Oh turn that into a career damn he
has more street cred than any of us
that's true well he got he first got
arrested when he was 13 and he was
released I think the day before he
turned 18 oh he tried as an adult I'm
not sure hmm because now he's fighting
the state but the state doesn't think
that he does there's anything more than
just his freedom because he did confess
so he is like partially under shady
circumstances though yeah so we'll see
what happens hello a lot of people do
you want to contact me and everybody
else you see go ahead and check the
description box below and follow our
social medias is the Grahams and
Twitter's for more videos click up there
baby
[Music]
you
[Music]